new york city reeling from another
violent weekend an oncology nurse by the
name of maria ambroccio is dead after
being knocked to the ground by
apparently a homeless mugger in times
square the new york post on their op-ed
page blaming city leaders for her death
and demanding an end to their soft on
crime policy saying quote enough every
day of their added delay ups the odds of
another tragedy it comes as the state's
democratic governor sees her plan for
criminal justice reform backfiring as at
least nine rikers island inmates are
reportedly back behind bars just weeks
after being released here's the reaction
former new york city police department
officer and unfiltered host dan bungino
dan good morning
hey good morning steve good to talk to
you it's a cover of the new york times
times square murder and the problem is
you know and and they addressed this in
the op-ed page of the new york post
there are 12 000 mentally ill homeless
people
on the streets of new york city and this
apparently was one of them
yeah a couple points steve for you know
i know you've been covering dylan
harrison all morning but uh it was a it
was the officer who was shot in georgia
but it was his first day on the job with
with that police department and i'm just
thinking of my first day on the job with
the 7-5 precinct as a police officer in
eastern new york brooklyn how
overwhelming your it is you're meeting
everyone you know getting to know people
getting to know the streets and then you
walk outside and
and then you're dead because some you
know animal just decides that it's going
to be your last day on earth
i mean i think we should all keep that
in mind i mean thankfully that's not our
jobs now right we don't worry about that
risk every day but police officers do
and it's just such a sad day but on the
topic you asked about what's so
disturbing about this dangerous climate
for police officers and obviously given
the context of the story citizens in
general
is that the left knows what works steve
that
you know that's what troubles me so much
it's like how are they so bad at this
when it comes to anything the economy
public safety and the answer is they
aren't they're not stupid they're doing
this deliberately i mean i lived through
the rejuvenation of new york city as did
listen you were working in new york
you've been with fox since the beginning
you know you saw it they know what works
broken windows style policing the
enforcement of the law and they're not
doing it which begs the really tragic
disturbing question i mean why is this
on purpose these aren't stupid people
well you answer the question why is it
because people i drive through times
square twice a day and it is like the
brightest spot
illuminated in new york city in the
middle of the night
but it's also one of the most dangerous
i mean this this guy
uh before he bumped it rammed into her
she hit her head and she wound up dying
this guy had
apparently gone into a total stranger's
apartment
down the street from where we are the
woman
said he sat on her couch screaming i'm
an african prince before uh he rummaged
through her stuff found 15 bucks then
ran to times square where he killed this
woman
yeah yeah i mean why i mean a lot
there's two real reasons right the
bigger ideological reason the the
radical left loves chaos the only way to
get people to forfeit over their civil
liberties is to get them scared but the
smaller reason why they do these things
and and they don't treat homeless people
and allow criminality to run wild is
because of the first reason the radical
left loves it and you don't have
politicians with any kind of guts de
blasio or other liberal mayors and
governors around the country willing to
stand up and say no my responsibility is
to take care of my citizens first
they're just not doing it steven you're
going to see more death and carnage as
these body bags pile up and it's the
most tragic story of our time it really
is absolutely but you know if people
feel scared they're going to be holding
the people responsible responsible so
let's i hope we'll see what happens all
right dan thank you very much we'll be
watching you later today and check out
his radio shows podcast and everything
else i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilny and
i'm ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis